dans le reste de l'actualité une autre
élection celle des représentants
syndicaux pour les salariés des très
petites entreprises et les employés à
domicile est méconnue cette élection est
organisée du 28 novembre 12 décembre
prochain et pour en savoir un peu plus
sur le sujet michael et demi d'euros
n'djamena - en plateau bonsoir michael
et dites nous combien de personnes sont
concernées par ces élections
professionnelles pour les tpe alors sur
l'ensemble du territoire ces élections
vont se tenir du 28 novembre au 12
décembre et vont concerner un peu plus
de quatre millions cinq cent mille à
personne et notamment 90 milles dans les
yvelines vous le disiez nicolas pour
voter à toutes les personnes qui
travaillent dans les entreprises de
moins de onze salariés et également les
employés à domicile
quel est l'intérêt pour ses salariés
michael de choisir des représentants
syndicaux alors c'est la deuxième fois
que de telles élections sont organisées
la première c'était en 2012
et l'objectif est simple que les
sahraouis choisissent eux mêmes leurs
représentants des représentants qui vont
par exemple négocier directement la
convention collective de la branche
professionnelle concrètement il s'agit
des conditions de travail formation la
sécurité santé ou encore chômage écoutez
à ce propos les représentants
départementaux de la cgt et de la cfdt
aujourd'hui ces salariés n'ont droit
qu'au minimum c'est-à-dire le code du
travail de travailler avec les syndicats
ça permet à un moment aussi pour le coup
de
je comment dire d'aller plus loin sur la
démarche de mieux défendre ses droits en
de mieux effectivement pouvoir en
discuter autour d'une table avec des
patrons c'est la seule occasion pour ces
salariés de petites entreprises ou de
particuliers de s'exprimer de choisir
l'organisation syndicale qu'il souhaite
voir porter leurs revendications
ça va peser bien sûr aussi sur la
représentativité globale des différentes
organisations syndicales vous l'aurez
donc compris l'enjeu est important pour
les syndicats en cas de bon résultat la
cfdt pourrait devenir le premier
syndicat de france à la place de la cgt
à noter enfin que les électeurs auront
le choix entre une trentaine
d'organisations syndicales et qu'ils
pourront voter par courrier ou via
internet sur le site que l'on peut voir
s'afficher à l'écran
éducation les questions en
travail.gouv.fr vous avez bien suivi
nicolas
merci michael pour toutes ces précisions